there's so many people that you see
either in this industry or just in life
in general that are going through their
days and may have everything they could
never want but they're not happy
confidence is the best I think you can
literally rock a trash bag if you have
confidence and I don't need to custom
whatever I don't need to do that to make
a great song Michael Jackson never did
it so I don't think I got to do it
either you know she's an American
actress singer and dancer in March 2016
she was cast in the spider-man film
homecoming as Michelle she began her
professional career as a fashion model
for Old Navy and macey
she zendaya and here's my take on her
top 10 rule to success rule number one
is our personal favorite I make sure to
stick around all the way to the end for
some special bonus clips also as she's
talking if you said something that
really resonates with you please leave
it in comments below put quotes around
it other people can be inspired as well
enjoy
[Music]
what's your message for viewers out
there about bond is really I would say
if you truly believe in something and
you really have a passion for something
then go for it I think there's a lot of
us who didn't have to go to and if
nothing's ever given to you and hard
work but if you really believe in it
just to do it
confidence is the best I think you can
literally rock a trash bag if you have
confidence literally Lady gaga does it
all the time she can rock whatever she
wants because she has that confidence
that makes you believe that it's the
coolest thing ever and I think that that
awesome you know when you see a
confident woman is I think there's
nothing more attractive or fabulous
about a confident woman because you know
that she loves herself and is in her own
skin and I think that's the best it's
the best accessory it's the best outfit
it's confident
well the best thing I've learned and
advice I could give me my younger self
is really to focus on happiness you know
happiness is a key because there's so
many people that you see either in this
industry or just in life in general that
are going through their days and may
have everything they could ever want but
they're not happy you know so you have
to focus on what makes you happy and
make decisions in your career in your
life that make you happy and so I've
been trying to do that and it's working
you know and and saying no to things
that are negative and saying no to
things that don't you don't want to do
you know so I think that that's my
biggest piece of advice something I do
or I try to do every day as I try to
make someone whether it be my team or my
life or whatever just happy or make try
to make them feel good or feel
comfortable or feel loved whatever it
may be it could be the littlest thing it
can be just saying oh you look really
pretty today or it could be something
even smaller than it-it's something
bigger than that you know it doesn't
really matter but it's just making a
conscious effort to make someone so good
and that could be a stranger or it could
be your mom you know I'm not pretending
to be something that I am NOT or
pretending to be this goody two-shoes or
whatever I'm just
myself and and I think that you know
then nobody can be disappointed in Who I
am as a person or I don't feel like I
have to hide or pretend because I'm not
I'm not I'm just beans and dance you
know and I'm just going through life and
learning out you know learning how to be
a young woman and it just you know and I
have that responsibility nothing it's a
responsibilities it isn't a little bit
of a weight sometimes absolutely but its
responsibility I got it I love that you
know if you don't get the part it wasn't
yours to begin with
so in that in Massachusetts are you I
feel like if the opportunities and
what's meant to happen to you is going
to happen to you and you just have to
trust that and you have to work hard so
what I did is I just I knew I knew
something was going to happen I did was
in a matter of if it was a matter of
when so I just worked hard until I got
there and I had the goal I had I knew
what I wanted and so when I came into LA
things happened a lot faster for me
because I had my goal I was ready to go
and I was a new face so it worked out
right that's right but of course there
was nose of course there was nose but at
the end of the day my I was like it's
going to happen it's going to happen
I've been taking a long time to like in
those four years since replay and
everything like that and our three or
however long it's been just taking the
time because hey I've been I've grown as
a woman and I mean you learn who you are
you come into your own you find out more
about yourself and that's a big
transitional period you know I mean when
you're growing into literally becoming a
woman so my thing is was how I
translated that and turn that into the
music and I mean how do I translate my
maturity and my growth in let people
connect to that make it a little more
real and and also on the same token is
this is you know I'm finally get a
chance to like really do the music that
I want to do you know I mean and there
is no sacrificing anything there's no
you know giving in there's no you know
people have opinions you know behind the
scenes is like what I Lane I should go
and what I need to do but I know what I
want yeah and that's my number one piece
of anyone who's doing anything in life
is you have to stick to your vision and
six your gut you know I'm saying is I'll
leave Olivia Pope gut you know with it
and we're never done you know acting
singing and dancing
I think are all things that came to me
naturally but they're all things that I
try to challenge myself on so I'm always
trying to push myself in every area of
the arts whether it be acting singing or
dancing it's about either whether it be
perfecting the dance that you already
know or learning a new style of dance
whether it be trying to hit a note that
you never thought you could hit or play
a character that is outside of your
range then you know that's something I
want to continue to do and continue to
to grow I think if you stop challenging
yourself and there's no there's no more
you stopped yourself but there's no
there's no limit to the things that
you're capable of so I think I'm going
to continue to challenge myself here's
my thing is I'm always very careful
about how I do like especially when it
comes to topics on music it's like you
can talk around things I'm not going to
say what you know I mean you talk around
things so it's like really can mean
whatever it wants to mean for whoever's
listening to it you know I'm saying it's
up to you to decide what that means to
you um and that's why like kind of how I
want to keep it and I think that's kind
of like the greatest in the world he's
just like Michael Jackson yeah and I
mean he talked around all kinds of
daintiness on creep itself like I
remember listening to it I don't know no
idea what immediately like someone
creeping like exactly what you put into
it exactly it's what you want to make it
and I think that that's the way that's
kind of like the loophole that's the way
to have edging music and laughs my older
fanbase whatever to enjoy the music and
understand it and also have young people
listen because they can it doesn't have
to be that and I don't need to custom
whatever I don't need to do that to make
a great song Michael Jackson ever did it
so I don't think I got to do it either
you know so um it's just I think it's a
balance you know I'm saying is going to
be edgy and push the limits but do it at
the right pace that's all this whole
kind of transition into womanhood is all
about pace taking my time making the
right step in BIOS when it needs to be
made you know not going to that I have
decided that I want to do what makes me
happy for a long as it makes me happy so
if that means and this is something my
parents have always told me that means I
wake up tomorrow and I decide that none
of this is making me happy it's not
fulfilling me it's making me a miserable
person I don't feel good as I do you
wanna go do a mouse
what I look like one the time we get
them you've never thought about it what
else you I would want to like I would
probably want to go go to school go to
college I want to make probably for like
um child psychology something unrelated
who knows I might wake up and say you
know what I want to be a doctor you know
what I want to be this I want to be that
I don't know what the future holds as
long as it makes me happy I got to find
a passion you know but for now this is
making me happy yeah I'm gonna keep
doing this especially if you're young in
this industry you can doubt it and
people like to not listen to you yeah
and so I just I'm not one of those
people that cannot be heard you know
everything so that causing it is very
important that people exercise their
their their voice and what they feel is
right your gut and your instinct
especially if you're in this industry as
a young person you have to follow your
heart and do what you think is right
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Romans asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I also love to know which of the rule
to the biggest impact on you what did
she say that left a profound mark that
you're going to immediately apply
something to your life or your business
leave it in the comments and I want to
see what you have to say I also want to
give a quick shout out to John Carter
thank you John for picking up a copy of
my book your one word and tweeting out
that picture of you at the beach hole in
it I hope you enjoy it thank you for
sharing the love man I appreciate it so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is
much love I'll see you soon
and I myself was taking a break everyone
needs to just hold off and not be on the
phone because we get so caught up in the
negativity of social media that we
forget to use it for a positive thing
you know I mean like when I use my
Twitter to say anything or to do
anything I juice it to make messages
that I think are important or to get out
things that I think will make people
laugh or funny you know what I mean
or won't you know I never I'm not going
to treat something negative or hurt
emotionally this is not who I am you
know what I mean and sometimes we get so
wrapped up in like oh it's funny or oh
this is how I feel and I am you know
you're allowed to express how you feel
but at the end of the day we're all
human beings like gosh you know we all
have you know we all have feelings but
you have to be loving of yourself and
get in touch with yourself and be happy
with yourself first I think it's less
about other people more about like I
have to do better than myself and like
if I feel like I reach a level then I
have to work harder you never never you
know the best you can always get but is
always room for improvement and that's
in every area that's not just as you
know artists or whatever but that's as a
human being I constantly tried to become
a better person like I'm like even if I
like let negative thoughts come in my
mind or I think some type of way I'm
unthinking petty I'm just like dude like
you're better than like yours into like
I'm good you know any of me I've been
making children's programming for a long
time and for me a lot of people ask me
like why are you still on Disney Channel
why do you still do that and to me it's
because I feel have a responsibility as
this young person that I am to create
positive programming for these young
people I have little kids that look up
to me I think of that as a
responsibility and I know there's so
many parents that come up to me and just
hearing them say thank you for being
that for my daughter for my son being
the inspiration for them that that is
that's everything to me